going to be talking about simping okay
and so as we get started I'm going to
ask a question to everybody
do you guys know what a simp actually is
I've been one
okay go for it yeah I've been one female
simp okay
so basically
in my experience as a simp that does way
too much for someone that would never do
the same for them
but I love him though so your citizen
what is what is two what is too much
like what did you essentially anything
when you're a simp you essentially
shouldn't be doing anything for that
person
so anything you do is too much but you
do as much as to think people might say
what is that your man
no but I love him no I was just
wondering like what is too much like
what were you doing okay in my example
okay he had a girlfriend but
you had a guy who already had a
girlfriend yeah yeah but so what are you
doing with him
I said chicken Yeah so basically you're
a side chick okay so okay I didn't know
he had a girlfriend yeah but when you
found out he had a girlfriend you stayed
with him right yeah because that's my
baby so you got side chick energy
no not in general because I don't want
people
I mean you brought this up
like in general if you're trying to wife
me don't have a girl however him
especially because I didn't find out he
had a girl for about what was it like
two three weeks
is
I'm the type of person that I go with
energy so I can't meet you in person and
it's good energy I will link you every
day so it's like you know like when
you're in love island or Big Brother
house two weeks is like two months
so essentially them two weeks was my two
months she's saying she loves a Thrills
I love the fruit so in my head I was
like yeah this is my man and your man
after two weeks how long has it been now
how long like how long until you cut it
off oh no no no that's that's oh you're
still with him
I mean it sounds like she said she still
loves him so so
it's kind on it when did I meet him so
you're saying let me just yeah it's been
about a year and a half one more time
wait wait wait hold on hold on a year
are you so okay so let me just so after
two three weeks you found out he has a
girlfriend yeah and instead of saying
you know what I'm gonna cut my losses
and get out no no you were like let me
just ride this till I die so she was not
listening to the advice
does it a girlfriend now oh hell no no
no no no no no so the girlfriend has no
idea Bros
I personally feel like she probably
knows but she don't know it's me so
that's fine
um
the question was is anyone
it looks like yes I just want to see how
hot this man is because there is no way
this is an average looking I'll just
show you I will show that I won't show
the uh yeah
I'm gonna grade him one to ten
anybody else been a simp
I think no no male male or female don't
lie guys
at some point what is a Sim what do you
what do you what do you what do you
define as a simp I I heard that I think
he's like okay so it's Sim right it's
someone who caters to anything and
everything a woman wants and actually
showers her with love and attention and
doesn't necessarily get it back
[Music]
that's a you shower her with everything
and you love her and you want her and
you show all this kind of stuff but
she's kind of like yeah so you kind of
simp without okay so you never you tell
him you've never been a simp for a woman
I've never been a Sim but uh I can uh I
can tell that I've been always
someone who's who's really caring and
someone who's as a man right if I think
if you if you if you were raised in the
rice household and you see your parents
or your father
taking care of their wives
and they raise you to be
they raised you to grow up to become a
gentleman
I think there's okay let's just like
okay I'm gonna step back and explain to
you okay let's just say at school yeah
you have this this kid a very smart kid
you know
but people don't call Smart Kids smart
kids they call them weirdos or like
something else different names because
they're smart right right so uh what I
don't understand is what if a man is
just a gentleman but end up like end up
quoting a Sim
have you ever as a man felt like you
were given more to a woman we always
then she than she was given to you we we
as a man to this day we always give more
than modern women give that's how I feel
okay you know because as a man as a
provider you know I think but you're
married though aren't you I am married
and uh and the reason why I say that is
because women expect more
from us than we do expect from them
[Music]
you know women expect more from from men
to do than we as a man expect women to
right to give us right so uh either way
whether you're a simple gentleman or a
gangster
whatever you call yourself you still are
the man
give you more
okay so why is it so why is the Sim so
narrow down to the gender though when it
comes to men that is my big question
because
I don't know many female simps to be
fair I had no money
the girls that like usually say they're
stamps it's like all they offer is [__]
thank you all right
90 of girls it's like what else do you
bring me you know why ninety percent go
ahead no no no no do you know why
because goals are socially accepted to
be since kojo Regal so when a girl does
too much
so right so say if a guy likes me and
he's going over the top I'm airing him
he's still messaging me I don't give him
attention he's buying me stuff you're
now a simp it's embarrassing right now
say if a guy don't text me back I still
message him like I don't know it's about
I'm still doing stuff for him
you're a girl so it's a bit more in
society people are gonna judge a girl
less for being a simp than a boy no but
uh
because to kind of Chase off the boys
but boys are not expected to chase
but as a woman what would you prefer
would you prefer I want guys for chasing
me okay so hang on that's a very
interesting um thing so if you want guys
to a certain extent right this is where
I'm gonna go so if you want a guy to
chase you yeah if a guy's constantly
chasing you and showing that he's always
about you you're gonna get bored with
that right because the guy I used to
tattoo I would probably see him two
three times a week and he'd probably
ring me every day
but when I ring him he don't ring back
but you like that though but if he Rings
me let me know but you like that though
right right
but like but like but like but you like
that but like if he rings me and I don't
call back there's an issue
no but the thing is women like that
Chase they like guys like to chase no no
but hang on if a guy is chasing you down
too much Fitness no exactly yeah too
much yeah it is it depends it depends
how I'm responding if I'm actively
responding to you in a way that suggests
you can still chat to me cool if I'm
airing out your thing stop what you're
doing immediately stop what you do how
are you it's not if I air you two one
too many times it's a actually just stop
chatting together guys why don't you
just say you're not interested guys this
is why because
let me just say to the camera this is
why nice guys finish last no let me like
let me explain to you why okay you
cannot do
that aggression
don't explain why right you say why
don't you just cut off the guy that's
chasing you but you don't really want
the attention because I promise you the
guy that I want is not giving me enough
attention that I don't need yours your
attention is feeding my ego however when
my man replies yeah go away okay so so
let me just so you're gonna use the
other guys for attention listen and then
chase after the guy you don't like
because how would you feel if you were
in their shoes because I'm a hypocrite
because you started you started you
started the podcast saying that men
ain't [__] but you kind of are being
ain't [__] to men yep I'm a hypocrite do
you know what it is
I feel like if I'm intentionally airing
your message or not responding to you
you know what it is if a guy is airing
my messages and I choose to double
triple message him I know what it is and
I'm choosing to be that person if you're
messaging me and I air you you message
me again and I air you but I enjoy the
attention you do give me when you're
messaging me picking me up but I'm
choosing to air you you know what it is
this is
what it is I go this is why I tell men
just focus on yourself
guys forget about yourself because you
will never ever ever be able to
understand the psychology of a woman no
because for as a guy right does that
make sense to us it does does that make
sense but because as a man if we say we
want X Y and Z that means we want X Y
and Z right go for it yeah I mean a
woman would say they want X Y and Z but
if you give them X Y and Z they're like
no I don't know if I want that it's like
but you said you wanted it I can't like
that's not me though personally if you
give me exactly what I want we're good
[Music]
he chases me and I let him stay there no
hang on you're actually with a man
that's not your man you're a side chick
you just said earlier you're a side
chick no not anymore but you were a side
chick you used to be a savior you know
why though you know what I didn't go in
saying I want to be next if I knew from
the beginning I'd rather I'd rather be
no no I'd rather be I mean I'd rather be
single yeah then than knowing that I'm a
friend let me learn with benefit yeah
right oh oh I'm buying this girl who has
the who has a boyfriend already I wonder
Let Me Lie the man no the man we don't
do that like we don't we don't Batman we
don't mind girls that has boyfriend
already let me know but for women it's
fine for them let me speak let me speak
no no finish finish bro but for
for for girls it's fine for them to know
them well in the head that this guy that
they're sleeping with I know their man
right but he wouldn't do that listen if
as men we know if our if a woman that
we're sleeping with yeah is getting
penis from somewhere else
sometimes sometimes sex is just sex
don't get me wrong I feel like there's
always an end goal to end up with
someone but sometimes you know in the
time that someone you're mad sexually
attracted to and they can stay around
until you find whatever you need to find
don't get me wrong if I met the guy and
you had to go from the jump I wouldn't
have entertained it sounds like a little
bit yeah I mean come on
two weeks
I have a serious question though so have
you ever asked him like what his
girlfriend has that you don't
if he um broke up with his girlfriend
impossible not with me no I'm saying if
he broke up with his girlfriend and said
I would just want to be impossible why
why is that impossible because he
cheated with me no but I'm saying no but
no but if he said I'm gonna break up
with my girlfriend and I'm gonna be with
you just you and me possible would you
be with him impossible is that I know
that's you wouldn't be here listen come
away
because you said you love this guy so
you would be with him right
am I a bit of an idiot for this guy
absolutely however
I'm a chosen idiot as in I choose to be
there you're a chosen idiot I feel like
the main chick is worse than the side
chick do you know why
because the side chick knows she's a
side chick she knows what her world is
she knows the main chick is thinking
that's my man oh that's I love him no we
both yeah but that but the manager gets
the commitment yeah
but he ain't leaving her foreign
so either way she is the chosen one do
you know what I mean there's no choice
on one in this situation
everybody's a twin you know what it is
there is no choice
if you're the chosen one you would be
about you do you know what I feel like
but if you are side chick she's she's a
side chick as well because yeah
he's like an evil of views what you
require in a relationship he's just
playing both of you he's telling that
you're my girl he's telling you I like
but she might she never you never know
she might know throughout all of human
history the top guys have had multiple
women they've always had a main chick in
the concubines so so in this situation
no no offense you're the concubine from
what I know of the situation she be
getting DMS from other girls so she semi
knows however I feel like there's a
difference between say if I'm with a man
that's how I'm with Drake and then all
of a sudden Drake's not with you
no let's say I'm officially with Drake
yeah but he's not weird and then all of
a sudden someone richer and more power
comes along am I necessarily going to
leave Drake just because something
better because so we only have money
you get what I'm saying as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation help and it helps make
what we do possible